drew barrymore is taking the steps to  officially intermarriage the actress  reportedly filed for divorce from her  husband will Kopelman three months after  the pair split according to the New York  Daily News the blended star filed the  divorce petition characterized as  uncontested at the Manhattan Supreme  Court in New York City the former couple  announced they were calling it quits  back in April after nearly four years of  marriage  drew and will Wed in 2012 and share two  daughters three-year-old olive and  two-year-old Frankie this is the 41 year  old actresses third divorce she was  previously married to her Charlie's  Angel co-star Tom green in 2001 and  Jerry Thomas in 1994